hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the women's section of
the American Cup it is the eighth time a
US Women's Champion at Grandmaster Irina
Crush versus a woman Grand Master tativa
abrahamian and it's uh like the title
suggests uh it's a game where the nimzo
Indian goes terribly wrong but it's not
um uh the the problem is not of course
Indian names and the problem is in one
particular move uh that makes all of it
possible but um it's a it's a very tough
game and it's it features a beautiful
Sacrifice by by Irina that um it's it's
very instructional and you guys will
learn a lot on how to deal with uh with
the names in this game so let's check it
out uh it is uh from the semi-finals uh
the other the other pair from the
semi-finals is um feeding Master Alice
Lee 13 year old who we've seen a couple
of her games against Nazi pakita they
they drew their game so they will play
another one uh as uh the rules are the
same as in the men's section so here we
have Ponta D4 Knight to F6 C5 4 and E6
with Knight to C3 and the bishop to B4
the names of Indian defense is on the
board we have E3 castles and now Bishop
to D3 The Bishop's attack against the
nimso Ponta D5 with C character C
characters and Knight to E2 so nothing
new here everything we've seen before
rookie 8 Bishop D2 We have C6 and now
castles Bishop back to D6 the bishop
doesn't want to overstay his welcome on
this diagonal Rook to C1 and now we have
Knight the A6 the Knight will now get
re-maneuvered to C7 and from there you
have a plenty of options and the the
position is a known one it's been
reached in 2021 in the uh Opera Euro
rapid preliminaries between Yani polish
and linear Dominguez Perez where nepo
lost the game after playing F3 it's a
fine move uh the the problem is not in
that move he just lost the game but here
we have A3 and it is now as of move 11
that we have a completely new game so
Knight to C7
uh we have found the F3 and now Pawn to
C5 a standard uh nimzoo move going after
White Center the characters with the
shop captures and now Knight the D4 now
the Knight is beautifully placed here
and we have Knight to E6 uh trying to
trade the weird Knight on C7 for the
very strong Knight on e4 and sure
um uh Irina says uh let's do it but uh
she wants the other Knight to join on D4
so here Bishop back to V6 is also the
bishop is now hanging on C5 so Bishop
back to V6 and now King to H1 always a
useful prophylactic idea getting the
king off with that diagonal uh Bishop to
D7 now preparing to bring the Rook into
the game also the bishop might end up on
this diagonal as you'll see later on
with Bishop to E1 opening up the queen
and the D file also the bishop can now
easily be re-maneuvered to any diagonal
uh Knight to C5 going after the bishop
here and this is the the really cool
moment in the game where the magic
starts happening uh the bishop is
attacked of course you do not want to
give up your light Square Bishop it's
such a magnificent piece and also you uh
you will lose the bishop pair the other
problem is the E3 Pawn is attacked so if
you play some like Queen D2 you defend
the pawn then
um uh Tata will happily trade here and
it's not it's not great uh here Irina
plays a most impressive idea and that is
Bishop back to B1 she gives up the E3
Pawn uh to keep the bishop pair so look
at this Rook captures on E3 Bishop to H
for now pins the Knight
uh and now the question is how do you
how do you continue playing this with
black probably bestest uh trade as many
pieces as possible as soon as possible
something like nice the E6 opens up the
bishop tries to trade off the knights
and even if the Knight comes to F5 which
is a spectacular square and arrogantly
Bishop to B5 and you're really tying up
white here still a very complicated game
a lot to do for both sides but it would
be the way to go however that have
played Rook to E5 here and now uh of
course the idea is if if Pawn to F4 she
wants to play Rook the H5 but uh Irina
goes Knight to G3 and now how do you how
do you react to this it's a such a
complicated position that uh after
analyzing the game I returned to this
position and I allowed the engine to
Crunch the numbers up until like that 45
I I thought there's no point in going
about that because even the engine has
no idea how to approach this position
with black it's uh the engine gives off
some weird ideas like let's play a rook
to see it C7 and then play G5 to kind of
try and trap the bishop here but also
we're stopping F4 if we play G5 so that
I mean it it's a bad position for black
maybe you can play it but you have to
play Angel moves to survive uh in the
game Bishop to C6 was played and uh it
it simply doesn't work and the problem
it does the the big problem why it
doesn't work is specifically because now
this Knight has something to capture and
Bishop to C6 does just that so look at
this Ponte F4 uh attacks the uh or let
me just show it to you instead of Bishop
to C6 let's say H6 was played uh now the
thing is after Pawn to F4 you can play
Rook to E8 and now if you try to file up
on the Knight with knights the H5 you
have this Knight C to E4 move that's the
big difference and now after Bishop
captures you're gonna play Rook captures
and now the Knight on D4 is hanging
that's the big difference from the line
that actually happened in the game and
now if not captures okay we're going to
play G captures your Pawn structure in
front of your king is a little messed up
but you have the bishop pair you have an
active Rook White Knight is hanging you
know you you're still in the game and
might even be better but after Bishop to
C6 this line no longer works as a
defensive resource for white because now
Pawn to F4 Rook back to E8 and now
Knight to H5 goes after the Knight on F6
and now you don't have Knight seat to E4
because after the same line uh now you
have Knight captures on C6 and the
Knight on D4 will no longer be a Target
like in the previous one so Bishop the
C6 was just a a beautiful way to help
Irina achieve uh you know the position's
full potential so Knight captures and C6
would be played B captors and now you
just trade Bishop captures you're gonna
play D captures and now Knight captures
with check G characters and now the
queen comes into the attack and this is
uh just dead lost for black there's no
way to play the sixth place unlike King
to h8 then Rook have to D1 you have to
uh got the F6 Pawn so let's say queen E7
now you pile up on the F6 Pawn you can
defend it with Bishop d8 but of course
white will just capture it captures
captures and now the shop captures and
uh you resign so that's why uh in this
line this particular line Knights the E4
doesn't work Knight C to D7 was played
seems like uh it should work it's the
same idea the Knight the defense df6
knight from uh uh D7 instead of from E4
but now we have Knight to F5 also very
nice idea would just beat the trade on
on C6 look at this Knight captures B
captress and Bishop to F5 uh you're
gonna mess up a black spawn structure
whatever black plays let's say Rook the
C8 here's a little bit Bishop captures
on D7 Queen captures and now even Bishop
captures and F6 where black cannot uh
recapture because Knight to F6 check
with 4K the king and the queen so Knight
c37 Knights the F5 was played also a
fine idea goes after the G7 Pawn G6 uh
forking both Knights but just Knights
the h 6 with the check King the f8 and
now Knight captures and F6 inviting the
other Knight to F6 Knight captures and
now just Knight to G4 going after the
Knight here and that's pretty much it
the the problem is Rook T6 doesn't work
because of the immediate F5 and now if G
captures nah there comes the bishop
captures on F5 and now after The Rook
moves now look at this bishop to E6 and
now uh the the Kraken has been Unleashed
uh there's no way to defend will
captures You're Gonna Play Knight
captures on F6 and that's it the next
move a nice night check will pick up the
queen or you try to to capture it but
still Bishop captures attacks the Queen
Once the queen moves you bring your
queen into the game you play last time
like rookie one cut off the king play
Checkmate or even just uh Queen G7 check
will be sufficient so that's why Rook
the E6 here just doesn't work so Knight
characters on G4 was played uh sort of a
last attempt by by that of not to resign
immediately and it comes with a with a
very good idea here Bishop captures on
the eight capturing the queen and now
Knight the E3 complicating things even
further now uh the queen and the Rook
are under attack and there's there's
only one move that gives white a clear
winning Advantage so feel free to pause
the video and finish this masterpiece
for Irina uh while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations and not just
looking for squares where you can hide
your queen and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
captures on B6 this is what Irina played
and it was in this position on move 28
that Tate of abrahamian resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so congratulations to everyone who
found Bishop captures on B6 the problem
with just the moving the queen okay
Queen F3 still gives white an advantage
but you you will still have to work for
your meal but lets you move the queen to
some weird Square just look after 78 and
now let's say Rook after E1 you try to
save your Rook D4 uh defends the Knight
now you have a brilliant Knight here
you're threatening and G2 the Rooks are
absolutely spectacular the bishop Perry
is slicing all the way here this would
not be an easy game for white uh so
instead Bishop capture some B6 was
played and here you resign because of a
very very simple uh matter the queen has
to be captured otherwise you're just
down a queen and the problem is after
Knight captures on D1 there's the the
and always celebrated fishing sug and
that is Bishop the C5 check you save
your bishop and now once the king moves
you will play Rook C captures or Rook F
captures and the one doesn't really
matter and you will be up a full dark
Square Bishop so of course down a piece
you have to resign no point in playing
this so yeah after Bishop captures on B6
beautiful way to end the game and uh
what a what a spectacular game to tackle
the the names of Indian defense it was
uh uh uh it all came down to this when
when this Knight the C5 was played
Bishop was attacked in this uh a
beautiful light Square Bishop uh going
after the opponent E3 and then just
Bishop to B1 simple as that give up a
pawn but you will make things very very
complicated for black and here it it
paid off uh so yeah if you like playing
the ninja if you like playing uh The
Bishop's attack against the NIMS or
maybe something that you should consider
in your own games not a bad uh not a bad
resource to know this giving giving up
of the E3 Pawn uh so yeah that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it very
nice done by Irina they will play one
more game and then if that strikes back
they will go into into rapid tie breaks
if not then Irina is off to the finals
uh so yeah I would like to thank Paul
hinemun do it around ravishing reptiles
YouTube Mike Wagner and uh thought
dreams for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day